prêter main forte oui mais pas à
n'importe quel prix
stage déguisé rémunération modique et
absence de contrat de travail
dans un communiqué posté sur les réseaux
sociaux ce lundi les organisations
étudiantes de l'université lyon sud
dénoncent les conditions dans lesquelles
des étudiants de 4e année de médecine
sont mobilisés par le plus grand centre
de prélèvement de la ville pour faire
passer des tests ducobu de 19 on estime
définition de dépistage sont ne font pas
partie des missions premières d'un
étudiant hospitalier et qu'elles doivent
être encadrés par un vrai contrat de
travail et par une rémunération qui leur
sont propres il ya seulement à l'intérêt
économique à employer en étudiants
hospitaliers en médecine parce qu'il est
payé seulement de 0 60 dollar et puis
bah forcément déplacées les étudiants au
lieu d'employer du vrai personnel pour
dépister basse a fait faire des
économies
des étudiants qui regrette également que
cette mission de dépistage soit décompté
de leur semaine de stage à l'hôpital et
qui mettent en doute son caractère
volontaire pratiquer faire des pcr à la
chaîne pour des étudiants médecins
pendant une semaine n'a aucun intérêt
pédagogique
le centre de dépistage du palais des
sports de gerland espère recevoir l'aide
de 15 à 20 étudiants par semaine sur
huit à douze semaines lors de la
première vague épidémique
ce sont les étudiants en médecine de
l'université de lyon est qu'ils ont été
appelés en renfort
interrogé par nos confrères de france 3
le professeur laurent responsable de ce
centre de dépistage met en avant une
contribution bénéfique pour les
étudiants une très grande partie
d'étudiants se sont plus aptes à faire
des prélèvements
à l'issue de cette semaine au centre de
dépistage depuis le 26 septembre 2020
plus de 55000 prélèvement nasopharyngé
ont été réalisés dans ce centre de
dépistage grâce notamment aux étudiants
en médecine face à une épidémie qui
continuent de progresser en france
les représentants des étudiants de lyon
sud craignent que leur mobilisation se
pérennise